cette zone il y à des serpents il y a
des mygales il va falloir que vous
formiez une phrase en trouvant des mots
sous les mygales et les serpente
si vous arrivez à le faire et bien un
hulu téléspectateurs gagnera une console
de jeu et nora et nelson c'est parti et
laura vous pouvez laisser tomber les
clés moi je vais je veux bien commencé
plus que je vais déjà faire les aidera
live alors recyclera donc soulève un de
ses amis et jaune et blanc mais pas non
mais si c'est en chine charge devient
[Rires]
l'égérie ils veulent avoir trois trucs à
manger le premier qui aura mangé les
trois trucs sera gagné peut-être une clé
à quelqu'un du public
j'aimerais lui donner d'accord les
cherry et durera trois clés à la fin il
y en aura une
vous n'êtes pas allé attention à 2,3 à
l'énoncé rien n'est impossible
j'allais très fort la thur je n'ai je
n'ai je n'ai pas le courage de mettre ma
main dans le
[Applaudissements]
on voit pas ce qu'il a il ya une sorte
d'énorme
il est ce genre de surprises où je veux
bien avisé pas collé dessus chacun votre
tour vous allez taper sur le clou avec
un celui qui termine par enfoncer le
clou bien sûr celui qui termine par
enfoncer le clou à gagner d'accord
attention il faut être stratège ont fait
ce coup là où ce couloir sur lui vous
voulez vous attendez le premier qui
réussit mais en fait non en fait c'est
sur un voilà exactement c'est sur un ca
me prenais suis là où je suis là parce
que rohff choisi on y va attention
attention c'est parti ça va deux fois
même famille a besoin des autres formes
voilà aulas
les gars jouent sans bricoleur duda
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
deuxième option un jeu trois
commissionnaires annoncé par le regarde
et lui c'est fini avec la bastille à ne
[Applaudissements]
pas manger ça c'est l'épreuve
m
dyson qui allaient à delson nathan là
j'y vais j'y vais vraiment bon sens vous
y allez la dette sociale
jg je veux vas-y vas-y giné gelé des
toits qu'il n'y ait rien du tout
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi alors des jeunes secteur des
serpents je n'ai pas peur des serveurs
ben c'est gagner maman
[Applaudissements]
attends je relis laissez pas traîner vos
mains parce que je vous sens aux
tensions dans la tronche mais jean-luc
voilà il est minuit et demi mais c'est
toujours attentionné mais julien alors
donc vous allez poser des énigmes à
olivier minne qui va tout mais il va
devoir répondre à des énigmes
pendant qu'il tournait à chaque fois
qu'une énigme se retrouver nous
donnerons d euros il sautait nous
[Musique]
info le tour des continents hall est
gravie difficilement mais ce l'est tenir
c'est quand même beaucoup rire qui saute
et le lit et me dit rien
[Applaudissements]
des continents on les grave y
difficilement mais ce l'est tenir c'est
quand même beaucoup rire qui sentent
elles elles font tourner continents chez
elle peut-être de boeuf aussi à deux
baffes l'onglet non d'arrondir la côte
locaux peut-être la corde
notre bon sens qui entoure le levant
torex le thorax du munster vient d'avoir
une minute pour trouver la clé non je
retiens sa table chacun soit cassé des
mêmes jarre c'est au jeu alors je vais
vous dire je découvre l'émersion on aime
ça 3 2 a vous avez une minute pour
trouver la clé tactique est basique
[Musique]
l'italie veut trouver la clé mais vous
avez encore 40 secondes a dit kelly
kelly a dit oui à sa solide de maxime le
premier sincèrement je sais c'est un
perroquet vite c'est là c'est le slip
d'isabelle
oui oui à l'accueil bravo c'est lui
[Applaudissements]